Esto que estáis viendo ahora mismo es la
CONSTITUCIÓN DE VENEZUELA.
Aquí hay muchas de las claves para entender
lo que está pasando en Venezuela y, lo que
es más importante: por qué no podemos hablar
de un golpe de estado en este país.
En este vídeo, te lo vamos a explicar.
…
Hay muchas formas de derrocar a un dictador:
revoluciones, transiciones pacíficas, pero,
al menos que yo recuerde, no hay ningún caso
en el que un líder jura el cargo para deponer
a un gobierno autoritario.
Porque, dejemos las cosas claras, lo que hay,
en Venezuela, es una dictadura.
La dictadura de Nicolás Maduro.
¡Y sí, ya sé lo que me vais a decir muchos!
¡Fonseca!
En Venezuela hay elecciones ¡Por supuesto
que las hay!
También hay elecciones en Bangladesh, Egipto
o Azerbaiyán.
Incluso en Corea del Norte tienen elecciones
legislativas cada 5 años y hay distintos
partidos políticos.
Tal cual como lo oís.
Sin embargo, una democracia necesita elecciones
libres, limpias y libertad de expresión.
Y, si recordáis, en este vídeo ya os explicábamos
cómo la libertad de expresión en es tan
escasa en Venezuela como el papel higiénico.
Y sí, ya lo sé, pese a la crisis humanitaria,
la violencia y las violaciones constantes
de derechos humanos, Nicolás Maduro todavía
cuenta con un enorme apoyo popular ¡Por supuesto
que es verdad!
La lección número 1 del manual de todo dictador
consiste en ganarte el apoyo de la mayoría
con enormes campañas de propaganda.
Y, por supuesto, la lección número 2 dice
que a cualquiera que te plante cara, le tienes
que meter en la cárcel.
Cuando controlas el poder judicial y legislativo,
es muy fácil acusar a un opositor de cualquier
delito.
En el caso de las monarquías árabes, a los
opositores se les acusa de estar conectados
con el terrorismo.
Y en el caso de Venezuela, se les acusa de
golpistas.
Y ahora estaréis pensando, vale, puede que
Nicolás Maduro sea un dictador, pero… Juan
Guaidó ha dado un golpe de estado.
A fin de cuentas, se ha proclamado como presidente
del gobierno sin ganar unas elecciones presidenciales
¿verdad?
¡Pues tampoco!
Veréis, un golpe de estado se define como
una toma del gobierno mediante el uso de la
fuerza por parte de un grupo que ostenta poder
dentro del propio gobierno, normalmente el
ejército.
Sin embargo, Juan Guaidó se ha proclamado
presidente a través de un artículo previsto
en la Constitución de Venezuela.
El artículo 233 permite que el presidente
de la Asamblea Nacional ocupe temporalmente
la presidencia de la República.
Es decir, que el líder del legislativo se
encargue de la jefatura del Estado y del Ejecutivo
venezolano hasta que se realicen nuevas elecciones
en menos de 30 días.
Así que quién está respetando escrupulosamente
la Constitución es la oposición, no Maduro.
Ahora bien, la pregunta que sí que nos podemos
hacer es… ¿Esto que está pasando en Venezuela…
es bueno o es malo?
¿De verdad es tan sencillo acabar con una
dictadura?
¿Basta con proclamar a otro presidente, que
lo reconozcan distintos países y… ya está?
Pues… mis queridos amigos de VisualPolitik,
nada más lejos de la realidad.
Por supuesto que nos encantaría poder descorchar
el champán con vosotros.
Sabemos que muchos venezolanos veis nuestro
canal.
Muchos nos habéis pedido por mensajes que
hagamos este vídeo.
Y sé que queréis una buena dosis de optimismo.
Pero, a veces, en política tenemos que dejar
las pasiones a un lado y ver las cosas con
frialdad.
Más que nada porque estamos hablando de la
vida de casi 30 millones de personas.
El final violento de muchas dictaduras ha
llevado a una guerra civil que ha dejado al
país peor aún de lo que estaba.
Ahí está el Iraq de Saddam Hussein o la
Libia de Gadafi.
¿Es esto lo que va a pasar en Venezuela?
¿Hay razones para ser optimistas con Venezuela?
Hoy… NO vamos a responder a estas preguntas
porque es imposible.
Pero sí vamos a daros unas claves para que
podáis formaros vuestras conclusiones con
más rigor.
Y para eso, como siempre, antes vamos a ver
un poco de historia.
EL FIN DE LA DEMOCRACIA
Quedaos con esta fecha: 1 de mayo de 2017.
En ese momento, el Parlamento de Venezuela
tenía una mayoría anti maduro.
Por supuesto, no hablamos de un único partido
que se opone a Maduro.
En realidad, los opositores a Maduro van desde
la derecha hasta la izquierda.
Pero esto poco importa.
Desde que arrancó 2016, el Parlamento había
sido declarado en desacato.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Qué gran delito cometió
la Asamblea Nacional.
Resulta que la causa del desacato fue aceptar
la participación de 3 diputados de la oposición
denunciados por el chavismo.
¿Por qué fueron denunciados?
Pues ni más ni menos que porque eran los
necesarios por la oposición para conformar
una mayoría de dos tercios.
Los dos tercios suponen una supermayoría
suficiente como para bloquear a Maduro.
Pero como el pueblo había elegido a la oposición,
Maduro movió los resortes para anular su
poder.
¡Yo convoco el poder constituyente originario
para lograr la paz que necesita la república!
¡Para lograr la paz que necesita la república!
¡Para derrotar el golpe fascista!
¡Y para que sea el pueblo, con su soberanía,
quien imponga la paz!
En ese momento, Maduro declaraba ilegal al
Parlamento del país, la llamada Asamblea
Nacional.
Es decir, anulaba el poder legislativo.
El único órgano que podía hacerle oposición
perdió todo su poder ¿Y qué ocurrió después?
Pues, básicamente, Maduro se inventó un
nuevo parlamento.
La llamada Asamblea Nacional CONSTITUYENTE.
Según el artículo 348 de la Constitución
Venezolana, Maduro puede convocar una asamblea
constituyente.
El objetivo de esta asamblea no es otro que
redactar una constitución ¿El problema?
Que esta asamblea nacional constituyente de
Maduro se ha convertido en un parlamento paralelo.
Para que os hagáis una idea, han llegado
a aprobar impuestos.
Ya me diréis que tiene que ver eso con la
constitución.
¡Pero no solo eso!
Que de los 545 diputados que tiene, 503 pertenecen
al Partido de Maduro, el Partido Socialista
Unido de Venezuela.
Tal cual como lo oís.
El resto son cargos vacantes.
Es decir, que se trata de un parlamento donde
todos los miembros son de la misma formación.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Qué pasa con el Parlamento
antiguo?
¿El que tenía distintos partidos políticos?
Pues se siguen reuniendo pero sin ningún
poder político.
A fin de cuentas, quien cuenta con el ejército
y la policía para hacer cumplir la ley es
Nicolás Maduro y la Asamblea Nacional Constituyente.
¡Pero aquí no termina la historia!
En 2018, Esta Asamblea Nacional Constituyente
donde todos sus miembros son del mismo partido,
convoca unas elecciones presidenciales.
Elecciones donde la mayoría de los partidos
no pueden presentarse a las elecciones porque
son ilegales y que tienen más trampas que
una escopeta de feria.
Tanto es así que el 60% de los votantes inscritos
se abstienen de ir a votar.
Como os podéis imaginar, el resultado de
esas elecciones fue tan predecible como el
final de La Pasión de Cristo.
Maduro arrasó.
Pero casi ningún país reconoció el resultado
¡Habéis oído bien!
Es decir, ya en Mayo de 2018, Mike Pence,
el Vicepresidente de los Estados Unidos decía
lo siguiente.
“Estados Unidos llama a estas elecciones
por su nombre: son una imposture.
Maduro debe organizar elecciones libres y
limpias y liberar a todos los presos políticos
inmediatamente y sin condiciones”
Y lo mismo pasó con Alemania, Colombia, Costa
Rica y, por supuesto, España.
Nadie reconoció la legitimidad de Maduro
para ser el presidente de Venezuela ¿El problema?
Que no había otra alternativa.
Y aquí es cuando llegamos a enero de 2019.
En este momento, Nicolás Maduro jura su cargo.
Pero no lo hace ante la Asamblea Nacional
sino ante el Tribunal Supremo.
Y ahí es cuando, acabado el primer mandato
de Maduro, con una jura inconstitucional para
iniciar su segundo mandato, el presidente
del Parlamento Venezolano, Juan Guaidó, se
proclama presidente ante el vacío de poder
que se ha generado ¿Por qué?
Pues bueno, porque representa al único órgano
que todavía tiene legitimidad democrática
en el país.
Y en ese momento es cuando todos los países
que no habían reconocido las elecciones presidenciales
que ganó Maduro, pasan a reconocer a Guaidó
como presidente legítimo de Venezuela: eso
incluye a Estados Unidos, Canadá y, muy probablemente,
la Unión Europea.
Pero ya sé lo que estáis pensando muchos
¿Y si todo esto fuera un movimiento orquestado
desde Washington?
A fin de cuentas, 5 minutos después de que
Guaidó saliera nombrado presidente interino,
ya contaba con las bendiciones de Washington…
¿Demasiada casualidad?
Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
¿A QUIÉN LE IMPORTA VENEZUELA?
Si seguís VisualPolitik desde hace tiempo,
ya lo sabéis muy bien: Venezuela es el país
con las mayores reservas de petróleo del
mundo.
Mucho más que Arabia Saudita, Rusia o Estados
Unidos ¿El problema?
¡Que apenas son capaces de venderlo!
Veréis, una cosa es tener zumo de dinosaurio
y otra muy distinta es poder ganar dinero
con tu zumo de dinosaurio.
Fijaos en esta gráfica.
Aquí se puede ver lo que cuesta sacar un
barril de crudo en distintos países.
Arabia Saudita tiene el barril más barato.
Por eso, da igual el precio de mercado del
petróleo: ellos siempre sacan beneficios.
Sin embargo, Venezuela está en el otro lado.
Es uno de los petróleos más caros del mundo.
Y la empresa que lo extrae, PDVSA, es un auténtico
caos.
En otras palabras, a duras penas son capaces
de producir crudo para que les salga rentable
con el precio del mercado internacional.
Para que os hagáis una idea, aunque sean
el país con más reservas del mundo, producen
menos crudo que Angola o Nigeria ¿Habéis
oído hablar alguna vez a algún político
de Washington preocuparse demasiado por el
régimen corrupto de Angola?
Pues eso.
Básicamente, por mucho petróleo que tengan,
su peso específico en la economía mundial
es más bien poco.
Especialmente en un momento donde, gracias
al fracking, todo hijo de vecino vende zumo
de dinosaurio.
Por otra parte, Trump ya se ha encargado de
restringir las inversiones a Venezuela.
Es decir, que los intereses que puedan tener
los bancos estadounidenses en posicionarse
de un lado u otro de la balanza son muy pocos.
Y sí, es cierto que Trump ha nombrado a ELLIOT
ABRAMS para gestionar todos los asuntos con
Venezuela.
ABRAMS colaboró en el intento de golpe de
estado contra Chavez en 2002.
Pero… seamos honestos, en principio no parece
que Estados Unidos esté demasiado preocupado
por Venezuela.
Ni siquiera por motivos de propaganda.
Por ejemplo, si miráis la portada online
de un periódico español como ELPAIS.COM,
veréis muchas noticias dedicadas a Venezuela.
Está claro que es un tema que nos importa
a los que hablamos en español.
Pero… llama la atención que la prensa angloparlante
apenas ha dedicado un par de noticias.
Esta es la portada de la FOREIGN AFFAIRS,
tal vez la revista más influyente en la política
de Estados Unidos.
Esta es la de la FOREIGN POLICY.
En fin… no hay demasiado entusiasmo en Estados
Unidos.
¿Y a que no adivináis quién si tiene algo
que decir en el futuro de Nicolás Maduro?
¡Lo habéis adivinado!
China se queda con el 28% de la producción
de petróleo de Venezuela para repagar su
deuda
¡Exacto!
Lo que ya hemos visto en tantos otros vídeos:
pagos de deuda a cambio de materias primas.
China necesita un suministrador de petróleo.
Y por eso ha estado prestando dinero a Maduro
como si no existiera mañana.
Beijing le ha prestado más de 50.000 millones
de dólares a Caracas.
Y, como no pueden pagar con dinero, pagan
con lo único que sobra en el país: zumo
de dinosaurio.
¿Todavía os preguntáis por qué China no
ha reconocido a Guaidó?
¡Exacto!
Nicolás Maduro es el único que todavía
puede garantizar el suministro de crudo.
A todo esto hay que sumarle el narcotráfico.
Según informes de la DEA, entre el 15 y el
20% de la coca que se mueve cada año pasa
por Venezuela.
Grandes figuras del régimen de Maduro como
Diosdado Cabello están implicadas en el tráfico
de drogas ilegales.
Podemos decir que Venezuela es hoy en día
un narcoestado.
Un lugar donde los traficantes pueden establecer
sus centros de operaciones con la ayuda de
las propias autoridades.
Pero todo esto está muy bien… sin embargo,
la gran pregunta es… ¿Puede haber una transición
democrática en Venezuela?
Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
¿QUÉ SE PUEDE HACER?
Como decíamos antes, la oposición a Venezuela
se caracteriza por una cosa: la fragmentación
absoluta.
Hablamos de montones de partidos políticos
con ideologías totalmente dispares: conservadores,
liberales e incluso socialdemócratas.
A diferencia de otros países como Polonia
o República Checa, donde sí había líderes
que aglutinaban la oposición al régimen,
hasta ahora no había una alternativa clara
a Maduro.
Sin embargo, todo esto parece haber cambiado
en muy poco tiempo.
Con tantísimo apoyo internacional, Juan Guaidó
sí puede hacer frente a Maduro.
Por supuesto, su cargo oficial es el de presidente
interino ¿Y esto qué significa?
Pues que, en cuanto sea posible, debe convocar
unas elecciones.
Es decir, que ocupa la presidencia de forma
provisional.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque esta es la
única buena noticia!
Veréis… las leyes y las buenas palabras
son muy importantes pero, en última instancia,
el poder lo tiene aquel con fuerza para imponer
la ley.
Por eso controlar a la policía y al ejército
es tan importante.
En otras palabras, Guaidó puede tener toda
la legitimidad que quiera, pero ¿Cómo puede
convocar unas elecciones si el ejército no
se lo permite?
¿Qué pasa con la policía?
Todo esto explica por qué, en los últimos
días, tanto Maduro como Guaidó han estado
intentando ganarse el apoyo de las fuerzas
de seguridad.
Nicolás Maduro pidió lealtad al Ejército:
"Tenemos que hacer respetar el poder de la
nación venezolana, con el poder militar"
Por el momento, el ejército siempre se ha
mantenido leal al régimen.
Los altos cargos del ejército venezolano
son completamente afines a Maduro.
Durante los últimos años, Caracas ha estado
subiendo el sueldo a sus militares año tras
año.
Un soldado raso en este país puede cobrar
bastante más que un médico.
Pero aún así, hablamos de alrededor de 80
dólares al mes.
En otras palabras, que tampoco es ninguna
fortuna ¿Es esto suficiente como para que
el ejército se subleve contra Maduro?
No lo sabemos.
Pero, desde luego, es importante tenerlo en
cuenta.
Quienes si viven mucho mejor son los altos
cargos del ejército ¿No me creéis?
Pues venios conmigo de paseo al… ¡BARRIO
SALAMANCA!
Para quienes no sois de España, el Barrio
Salamanca es algo así como el Manhattan de
Madrid: una de las zonas más lujosas y céntricas
de la capital.
En este zona, prácticamente todo el mundo
vota a partidos conservadores y prácticamente
todo el mundo tiene una renta media alta.
Hacia el año 2010, los únicos venezolanos
que vivían por aquí eran los miembros de
la oposición en el exilio.
Gente como la familia de Henrique Capriles
han hecho varias inversiones por aquí.
Pero, con el paso de los años, han llegado
más y más chavistas.
Tanto es así que, algunos empiezan a llamar
al Barrio Salamanca la “little Venezuela”.
"Me encuentro algunas veces sentado en restaurantes
en Madrid al lado de personas a quienes no
me sentiría cómodo de ver en Caracas", dijo
Leopoldo López Gil, padre de Leopoldo López,
un líder opositor en arresto domiciliario.
Algunos casos fueron tan sonados como el de
la enfermera de Hugo Chávez.
En 2015 compró una casa por más de 1,8 millones
de euros en metálico.
Tal cual.
Y así otros tantos casos.
Gente que llega con maletines de billetes
y compra auténticos apartamentos de lujo
con precios nachovidalianos.
Por ejemplo, también se ha visto varias veces
saliendo por Madrid a una de las hijas del
Ministro de Defensa de Venezuela.
En otras palabras, que hay una huída de capitales
por parte de muchos oficiales de Maduro.
Gente que quiere asegurarse un lugar al que
marcharse en caso de que todo se vaya a pique.
Y esto es una oportunidad para hacer presión.
Por ejemplo, España puede poner sanciones
económicas a los oficiales venezolanos.
Medidas que impedirían este tipo de movimientos.
No es nada nuevo.
Es exactamente lo mismo que se ha hecho en
otros casos como Corea del Norte.
Este tipo de medidas podrían ser muy efectivas
para poner más presión a todos estos cargos
del ejército para que pasaran a apoyar a
la oposición democrática.
¡Pero ya sé lo que me vais a decir algunos!
¿Y qué pasaría si el ejército no se posiciona
a favor de Guaidó?
¿Van a seguir apoyando a un presidente a
quien no reconocen ni en los países vecinos
ni en Estados Unidos?
Lo cierto es podríamos vernos en otra situación
de estancamiento perpetuo.
Sí, Venezuela podría aislarse aún mas y
mantener el régimen de Maduro.
Hay varios precedentes de esto.
Sin ir más lejos, la China de Mao Tse Tung.
Estados Unidos no reconocía el gobierno de
Beijing.
Para ellos, el auténtico gobierno de China
era el de Tsan Kai Tsek en Taiwan.
Esta situación se prolongó durante varias
décadas.
Otra posibilidad sería una guerra abierta.
Es decir, que Maduro lanzara toda la fuerza
de su ejército contra Guaidó y este tuviera
que pedir ayuda internacional.
Francamente, y esta es nuestra percepción
personal, es difícil que ocurra.
No parece que Estados Unidos o la Unión Europea
estén dispuestos a arriesgar tanto.
Y, desde luego, sería un escenario malo para
todos.
Incluído el propio Maduro.
Las guerras son impredecibles.
Y no sería la primera vez que un dictador
intenta escapar de su palacio y, por el camino,
le encuentran unos opositores.
Fijaos en lo que pasó con Mussolini, Ceaucescu
o Gadafi.
Dudo mucho que Maduro esté dispuesto a arriesgarse
a tener un final parecido.
Pero todo esto no son más que conjeturas.
Y por eso, turno para ti ¿Qué crees que
va a pasar en Venezuela?
¿Realmente veremos una transición democrática?
¿Conseguirá aferrarse al poder Nicolás
Maduro?
¿O tal vez una facción de su propio ejército
le termine dando la espalda?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Y por cierto, muchas gracias a GERARDO ROBLEDILLO,
de EXPATISTAN.COM por poner las voces en off
de este vídeo.
Y como siempre no olvidéis que publicamos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribíos a VisualPolitik y dadle a la campanita
para no perderos ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo.
Un abrazo y hasta pronto.